ok tout juste dix jours de l'élection de
miss france la liste complète des
cadeaux reçus par les miss vient de
sortir les 29 candidats qui devraient
ainsi recevoir une tablette c'est une
merveille du monde tablettes tactiles
démontre une garde-robe complète du
maquillage des kits de voyage des
cadeaux pouvant aller jusqu'à 50 7000
euros pour la future gagnante petit
récap et ça ça a choqué est ce que ça
vous choque chez vous dis non non
7 millions alors que la prochaine
élection du concours miss france devrait
se dérouler le 19 décembre en direct du
puy du fou
la presse s'est intéressé de plus près
aux incroyable cadeau offert aux
participants à ce concours
ça a quand même été une belle année pour
vous clémence les cadeaux impressionnant
qui dans cette période font polémique
on a un rôle c'est de faire rêver les
gens peuvent comme nous vous l'avions
révélé dans tpm paix une miss france
toucherait un salaire fixe de 3000 à
5000 euros par mois en plus de sa
viennent s'ajouter un magnifique
appartement dans le centre de paris dont
le loyer qui en charge pendant un an un
ordinateur 15 pouces une télévision
dernière génération la mise à
disposition à coiffeur durant un an un
séjour de 7 jours et 6 nuits dans un
hôtel de versailles pour deux personnes
ainsi qu'une voiture électrique
les cinq finalistes repartiront quant à
elles avec des mondes d'une célèbre
marque de joaillerie un smartphone ainsi
qu'une paire d'écouteurs sans fil ça
vaut le déplacement
l'ensemble des miss repartiront avec une
pléiade d'autres surprises une montagne
de cadeaux qui ont pleine crise
sanitaire n'est pas du meilleur goût
selon certains sur les réseaux sociaux
de nombreux internautes se dit choquée
je trouve cela honteux autant d'argent
gaspillé alors qu'avec la crise unitaire
duo qu'ovide beaucoup de personnes se
retrouvent démunis
alors comprenez vous la polémique autour
des cadeaux faits aux miss
chérie on vous pose la question
également chez vous oui non bat delphine
mais je me tourne vers toi tout de suite
ma chérie alors non bah oui mais non en
fait c'est le jeu c'est le jeu tout
simplement et chaque année les miss
gagne la même chose et voilà moi je sens
qu'il faut ça correct moi c'est comme si
don à prendre à l'essai on disait
pourquoi c'est la même chose je voulais
donner cet exemple dans l'est dans les
émissions où il ya des gains d'argent on
va pas dire ok on est encore vide où on
est en pause qu'ovide alors on va tous /
10 c'est la même chose aussi faire un
peu rêver les gens et en campus miss
france l anonymat la base c'est pas une
star et il ya plein de jeunes filles qui
n'ont encore jamais pris l'avion qui
prennent l'avion pour la première fois
enfin cette année elles sont à
versailles est un habitué des leçons
dans les trucs paradisiaque moi j'étais
par exemple à cancun à versailles c'est
magnifique je connais c'est un mec tu
habitais la barre qui chaque année donc
les la gagnante par exemple remporte la
gagnante remporte le voyage avec son
accompagnant donc si c'est à cancun elle
remporte le voyage accent accompagnant
donc là j'espère que ce sera pas juste
un verre ça va baisser
ça c'est une bonne anecdote ou pas la
bride à moi j'avais remporté le voyage
center parcs
oui ça think i lewis à tata choc
pardon ça se sent que oui en fait oui
parce que je me dis 57 mille euros total
pendant que donc certes déjà locaux
vides en fait c'est respectueux envers
le québec mais c'est aussi et
respectueux envers les personnes ne sais
pas qui meurent de faim dans les rues
alors laissez la développer la police il
a parlé elle m'a fait je trouve ça
vraiment dommage dans le sens où déjà
mon sincèrement je trouve que le
principe du concours de beauté c'est
déjà quelque chose d'un petit peu bête
selon moi parce que du coup ça fout des
stéréotypes un peu de beauté sa complexe
ça fait complique et des cabines mais
c'est vrai nous regarde pas comme ça
mais en fait je sais pas je veux dire
donnait 57 mille euros juste une femme
parce qu'elle est belle et intelligente
je trouve ça vraiment dommage dans le
sens où il y en a plein qui mériterait
d'avoir de la nourriture d'autres choses
en fait je suis un empêchement
quand vous entendez ça parce que des
filles vous êtes une ancienne miss ça
n'a juste rien à voir effectivement moi
si j'avais pas été miss france je serais
pas là aujourd'hui donc sa réouverture
si on s'était croisés si c'est moi de me
françois rétro c'est que même avec miss
france est sans travail
au bout d'un moment on fait non plus pas
le après miss france il faut pas oublier
que pendant l'année miss france on gagne
aussi un salaire c'est un boulot de
dingue d'être miss france à ça va
paraître un monsieur qui ne dort pas
beaucoup se consacre six jours sur sept
on se réveille très chaud on est
maquillée tous les jours au bout d'un
moment même la peau vachin on se couche
très tard on est crevé on a un salaire
et les fip aussi le motiver et c'est le
rêve de princesse preuve il ya une des
bijoux ont gagné doivent ils ont gâté
les voilà c'est beau c'est oui nicolas
bon après c'est gagnant gagnant c'est
les changes marchés en 10 derrière pelé
et vous faites la promotion vendre des
marques est alors voilà tout le monde
s'y retrouve donc c'est pas de l'argent
cash qui est dépensé projectile qui a
totalement raison d'ailleurs sur ce
qu'elle dit mais sélection de
marchandises s'est passé avec la cie
sexy et c'est le principe de l'offre et
weibo tellement des missions dans
lesquelles les candidats se donne du mal
intellectuellement physiquement et gagne
rien du tout en question pour un
champion ils ont ils ont une vraie
qualité cd ans gagnât pauvre
dictionnaire là y'a pas que la gagnante
qui a decade effet des candidates ont
des cadeaux et moi pardon mais je trouve
ça honteux en termes de signal envoyé
c'est la génération instagram c zéro
talent plein de cadeaux sans rien faire
sans rien a raillé et à cette fois c'est
vrai sont elles font rire à paris un bel
et les reins c'est comme ça de cadeaux
je suis consterné de symbian aujourd'hui
je vais demander ce que j'aimerais
demander l'avis de notre vraie miss ici
valérie bédard regarder autour des
questions et j'allais dire qu'est ce que
ça t'enlève à toi qu'on leur donne des
caméras elle bonjour ça me sera vite
pour l on tire des leçons c'est une
aventure exceptionnelle pour verbal sera
une fois dans leur vie parce qu'il ya
une élue et toutes les autres vont
rentrer chez elles elles vont vivre il
n'y a pas que les organes r y'a pas que
malgré lui il ya trois nuls elles vont
vivre une aventure extraordinaire elles
vont avoir une tablette etc sur des
souvenirs et donc et chopra choix au
plus des manuels sont calmes à terre qui
change
mais on n'empêche pas ces cadeaux aux
plus démunis pour les donner aux jeunes
filles
ces voix là c'est les verts de choses
qui n'ont rien à voir c'est en fait
c'est vraiment c'est un échange de tirs
a dit un jour en fait c'est vraiment
c'est gagnant gagnant
j'attendais ça il m'a dit là dedans
gomis ronces tu voir ces gars sympa ce
soir un peu comme swatch est plus que
c'était un livre mon nom mais c'est une
société privée miss france miss france
il envie donnait 57 mille euros à des à
3 me soit une miss cette société privée
ya des marques comme a dit nicholas et d
échange gagnant-gagnant sédé marc sait
alors ce moment là ici quand vous faites
qu'en fait gagner en raison des échanges
la ceiba noël faucher les magasins par
isabey qui ont un appart en alla alors
on arrête aussi de faire ça parce que
c'est la crise pas d'ailleurs si on ne
peut arrêter de diviser parce qu'on
donne des cadeaux à la raison et donne
alors un des cadeaux pma anne marie
guillaume non tanguy on parle de deux
questions pour un champion j'adore
guillaume questions pour un champion
c'est l'argent du contribuable faut
parer à ça balance et non 400 mais les
années je vais douga covin ça va pas
changer le problème ça sur quelle forme
ils ont gagné ça c'est tout plein de
gens qu'on pas de mérite à gagner est ce
que nous on a du mérite à gala